[Applaudissements]
je suis venu vous parler d'une prise de
conscience qui a bouleversé ma
conception de la création d'entreprise
j'ai 63 ans j'ai créé ma première
entreprise en 1977 alors que j'étais
encore étudiant en troisième année
d'école de commerce période d'ailleurs
où il était particulièrement compliqué
de créer une entreprise
quand on était jeune et encore étudiant
j'ai créé ou repris plus de 40 sociétés
durant les 40 dernières années j'ai eu
des échecs et j'ai eu des succès mais ce
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est l'évolution
de plus en plus rapide des marchés sur
lequel j'ai pu avoir à travailler
je pense en particulier à la
distribution alimentaire à la cosmétique
à l'optique ou telle h domaine dans
lequel j'ai pu travailler fort de ces
expériences j'ai décidé de créer une
activité autour du numérique
il s'agit de faire apprendre à peindre
grâce à une tablette numérique un
programme adapté et un pinceau que j'ai
conçu comme toutes mes activités
précédentes
j'ai mis un temps certain à organiser
mon projet j'ai créé mon concept
j'ai fait faire une étude de marché et
études de marché qui s'est avérée
positive
j'ai organisé un prévisionnel c'est à
dire que j'ai essayé autant que faire se
peut de d'imaginer mon chiffre
d'affaires et mon prévisionnel de
dépenses pendant les trois prochaines
années
prévisionnel d'ailleurs qui m'a servi à
obtenir un financement de ce projet j'ai
commencé à recruter
et cerise sur le gâteau j'ai obtenu un
prix de l'innovation
sincèrement je pense que c'est un des
projets sur lesquels j'ai eu le plus à
travailler lors d'une réunion à saint
brieuc j'ai rencontré une personne qui
était reconnue dans ce domaine de
l'économie numérique
et très fier du projet que j'étais en
train de porter je me suis dit tiens je
vais lui expliquer avec moult détails là
où j'en étais et très sincèrement
j'attendais un peu d'encouragement et
quelle a été ma surprise voir ma
déception lorsqu'il m'a dit que je me
plante est totalement dans la manière
dont j'ai abordé mon sujet et que mes
chances de succès en était très très
limité ma première réaction a été de me
révolter
comment me dire que je vais me planter
alors que je m'étais donné toutes les
chances de succès pour ce projet et
voilà ce qui m'a dit qu'ils main
particulièrement fait réfléchir
tu as trop prévu d'argent sur un projet
qui n'a pas encore été soumis à des
futurs utilisateurs qui a trop de
certitudes sur l'intérêt même de ton
projet et tu es trop sûr tu es trop sûr
de la manière dont il faut le concevoir
l'organiser et le vent et la rajouter
ses conseils commence par communiqué
avec des futurs utilisateurs demandent
leur leur avis sur ce que tu as prévu
pour eux et surtout surtout demande leur
leur soutien sincèrement j'ai mis encore
un certain temps à comprendre ce que
voulait me dire
et voilà ce que j'en ai compris les
règles du jeu ont changé
en gros le marketing telles que je les a
pris utilisez enseigné durant de très
nombreuses années
c'est à dire l'analyse des besoins des
consommateurs et la manière dont il faut
utiliser pour influencer leur
comportement a été totalement remise en
cause par internet
ce comportement de consommateur s'en est
trouvé totalement modifié avant on
passait le plus clair de son temps à
organiser son projet avant de le
soumettre un panel de consommateurs par
le truchement de tubes de marché ou de
marché test
maintenant maintenant le consommateur
est prêt à vous aider si vous considérez
comme un acteur et non seulement comme
un utilisateur
il peut adhérer à votre projet au plus
tôt de sa conception
il peut vous aider à le mettre au point
il peut surtout de vous aider à son
développement
si le projet correspond bien à l'un de
ses besoins
alors il vous aidera à le concevoir à le
fabriquer à le financer et à le vendre
oui mais comment il faut savoir en tous
entourés d'une communauté de ses futurs
utilisateurs
il faut savoir les faire participer tout
au long du processus de la fabrication
de votre concept ou d'autres produits
il faut tenir compte de leur avis et
surtout leur dire qu'est-ce que vous
avez modifié dans votre projet grâce à
leur apport il faut laisser il faut les
informer au fur et à mesure du
développement de votre concept
et quand vous leur est lancé il faut
continuer à le faire à leur faire réagir
par rapport à votre propre développement
vos futurs consommateurs sont devenus
des consom acteurs ils sont vos testeurs
vos conseils vos banquiers vos
commerciaux ils peuvent vous aider à
créer de la valeur
ils sont les garants de votre succès en
maintenant vous pouvez créer un produit
et un service et le proposer à ses
utilisateurs
alors que ni le produit ni le service
existe si c'est un échec
aucune conséquence si c'est un succès
alors vous leur expliquez que le produit
n'est pas totalement mise au point et
non seulement ils attendront mais ils
vous indiqueront les modifications
apportées au fur et à mesure de sa
conception
vous pouvez également lancer un produit
alors qu'il n'est pas encore totalement
terminée là également
ils vous aideront à le mettre au point
et surtout ils vous apporteront les
premiers financements mais vous me direz
quel intérêt ont ces futurs utilisateurs
vous aider après réflexion j'ai
considéré qu'il y avait j'allais dire
deux grands cas qui pouvait se présenter
et qui faisont qu'il faisait qu' il
était motivé à vous aider
le premier ils agissent par conviction
ils sont motivés par une mission et par
des valeurs la deuxième raison bain
simplement il souhaite un produit le
plus adapté à leur cas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à un vrai
mouvement de co-création pour cela j'ai
relevé un article de journal qui
relètent qui reflète pardon une étude
qui a été faite sur une entreprise cette
emprise s'appelle musique qu'ils
entreprises japonaises de d'accessoires
de bureau et de maisons et voilà ce que
les quelques lignes qui résument leur
étude des chercheurs ont comparé des
produits conçus par les cultes à des
clips de musique à des produits co créée
avec des consommateurs par le truchement
d'une plateforme web
les produits qu créées et ont généré 5
fois plus de revenus et ont été six fois
plus profitable durant les cinq années
suivantes que les produits conçus de
façon traditionnelle
roger j'ai donc décidé de m'entourer
d'une communauté j'ai recruté un
community manager qui en six mois a
suscité l'intérêt de milliers de
peintres amateurs que nous suivons de
manière quotidienne alors nous le
faisons au travers de plateformes telles
que facebook linkedin twitter interest
et instagram la richesse l'information
recueillie la pertinence des réponses
apportées et là qu'en plus la complicité
qui s'installe entre nous m'a totalement
impressionné et mme impressionnèrent
toujours cela m'a amené à complètement
remettre à plat mon projet et à monter
un nouveau projet sur la base d'une
collaboration beaucoup plus importantes
comme système très collaboratif
aujourd'hui je me sens plus fort dans ce
projet plus soutenue je me sens engagé
et je me sens redevable de cette ex
périence j'ai souhaité en tirer une
raide un peu plus générale que
j'aimerais vous soumettre vous
consommateurs
vous avez compris que vous avez encore
plus aujourd'hui qu'hier le pouvoir de
créer votre environnement et que vous en
devenez responsable en donnant les
moyens une entreprise de naître et de
s'est développée vous devenez le
responsable de son influence sur vos
usages vous avez entre vos mains le
devenir de l'entreprise de son
développement et de ses emplois vous
êtes l'acteur principal du monde
économique qui vous entourent acteurs
aussi car vous pouvez vous également
être créateur de valeur
rien n'est plus facile aujourd'hui que
de créer sa propre activité
je veux dire par là que jamais cela n a
été aussi facile vous pouvez vous même
vous entourer d'une communauté parler de
votre projet et créer ainsi votre
activité votre service votre emploi j'ai
pris conscience que le consommateur et
l'entreprise n'ont jamais été autant en
interaction que l'entreprise est le
reflet d'un groupe de consommateurs et
que le consommateur peut participer à
une aventure entrepreneuriale
imaginons imaginons que nous prenions
réellement conscience de cela
alors nous aurons l'espoir de changer le
monde qui nous entoure
car en changeant le comportement des
entreprises nous changerons notre
environnement
merci
[Applaudissements]